[Musique]
suite à la présence du petit coléoptère
des ruches dans le sud de l'île une
réunion s'est tenue ce vendredi 22
juillet au département le président
cyrille melchior ainsi que son premier
vice-président serge hoareau délégué aux
affaires agricoles ont reçu les
présidents d'associations pour le
développement de l'apiculture le
département assumera sa part de
responsabilité parce que nous sommes au
plus près des agriculteurs nous sommes
là pour les accompagner
on va faire en sorte que cette crise
soit surmontée et ce matin donc nous
avons organisé cette réunion de travail
avec les acteurs peuvent tout simplement
déjà les écouter et ensemble construire
un chemin des solutions pour que et bien
on puisse relever ce nouveau défi une
réunion qui a permis d'esquisser un plan
d'action partagé et concertée pour
lutter contre ce fléau la situation est
inquiétante aujourd'hui puisque nous
avons vu qui a 11 rue chez qui ont fait
l'objet de destruction puisque nous
sommes dans une hutte aujourd'hui
urgente et est rapide mais je crois
qu'il faut pas rester sur cette posture
de dire qu'il faut détruire puisqu'il
faut peut-être qu'on se prépare à vivre
avec la présence de ce petit coléoptère
dans nos ruchers il faut donc anticiper
d'autres solutions pour pouvoir
accompagner les apiculteurs et la
filière miel à la réunion et notamment
pouvoir anticiper sur la commande de
pièges pour essayer jeudi mais de
contenir cette invasion et et faire en
sorte que le département soit déjà dans
le camp des réactifs et apporter une
première solution face à cette situation
très inquiétante et parfois même je
dirais qui affecte énormément nos
apiculteurs parce que c'est leur outil
de travail qui est complètement détruit
et pour recommencer c'est un travail de
longue haleine c'est aussi ce côté
humain que nous devons accompagner et
bien évidemment le côté économique en
essayant de sauver aussi l'outil qu'est
la coop et miel un groupe de travail
sera lancée très prochainement pour
trouver les solutions les plus efficaces
afin d'accompagner les acteurs de la
filière aux attentes
[Musique]
non